for that I went into this individual's
profile
and if I'm not mistaken this individual
is even involved in public Jamal are you
ready to reach your ultimate potential
are you looking for long-lasting
relationships and ultimate Finance
it's time to join the Muslim Alpha
program The Ultimate Guide to
masculinity based on the Quran sign up
today use code Ali 25 for a 25 discount
so there is this new phenomena Happening
by individuals who are going to the
Kaaba some of them who are who identify
as being queer from the lgbtqt community
some of them who have feminine very
strong feminine looking features and
they are going to the Care Bear and
doing videos we're going to be talking
about if what they're doing is halal
Haram and we're going to go through the
issue of hermaphrodites I think that's
what they called forgive me
hermaphrodites yeah who are individuals
who are born with the both male and
female genitalia and what is ruling in
Islam pertaining to these individuals
let's watch these two videos and come
back inshallah because there are
important lessons to be learned because
some people are deriving Islam in their
rulings from their Uncle from their
logic we don't follow your opinion or
your logic we follow Islam let's go now
when I saw that I went into this
individual's profile
and if I'm not mistaken this interview
is even involved in public Jamal meaning
they give Dao to Muslims yeah the core
people give them the sea Etc
I did my research as much as I can and I
came to the conclusion that I do not
know and I cannot Clearly say if this is
a man or if this is a woman I don't know
if this individual is a hermaphrodite I
hope I pronounced that right yeah that
if they're both if they're born with
both agendas now let's quickly tackle
the one who says that he is or she is a
queer now this individual in Islam
number one is it haram for this
individual who might be a homosexual who
might be a queer who might be a whatever
it may be yeah entering the Haram or
doing
um argument's sake coming and doing
umrah there is no evidence from Islam in
the Quran of the Sunnah to say that such
individual who's indulged in these sins
yes is is it haram for them be a Muslim
no it's not they are still a Believer as
long as they do not say that their
action what they're doing is or them
themselves having this is halal or them
acting on its Halal if they deem it to
be Haram and they say that this is
something that this is how they are okay
they can say I have these desires but to
say that this is halal makes you a cafe
if you say this desire it's Haram you're
a Believer that's sinning it's as good
as seeing somebody who commits adultery
drinks alcohol involved in river which
can be caused as worse in the context of
his Waging War against Allah and his
messenger and how many people are
involved in Reba how many people do in
adultery and alcohol yes that's the
point there do we say they cannot come
to Umbra no this is jahil this has been
ignorant I mean I'm hearing some Medina
students
which I'm not going to mention was
sitting in their home they have no
experience in the Tao they have no
knowledge they come with this attitude
of just because something looks abnormal
or they deem that it looks Haram it is
Haram
oh that's time you studied Medina did
you know one way mind blown I'm Ali
needs dawah I'm Ali Jahin when I see
these individuals who have zero
experience in the dawah and they studied
in Medina
when they come with this stuff it blows
my mind did you not learn anything
simple principles of Islam did you not
learn
anywhere it's digressing the point is
what that that doesn't make them a
disbeliever neither can we say it is
Haram for them to come and perform
however if somebody does a video if I do
a video I got on and go I'm an adulterer
I'm involved in River I wage warn
Alana's messenger I drink alcohol
now you are openly publicizing your sin
and the prophet salallahu said every son
of Adam will be forgiven except those
who publicly publicize their sin yes now
if people are coming and bullying and
saying they shouldn't be allowed and
they start you are a five-star grade a
jail ignorant how could you say someone
who's indulgent sins what if it may be
cannot come to the Haram if you are
someone who commits
alcohol drink whatever murder whatever
it may be does that mean you cannot come
to the Haram so let's be balanced there
are two extremes one whoa who goes you
pray whatever you do you act upon it no
problem one no so the point is that
addressing the queer because you are
openly propagating Islam deals with this
you know as we know them is going to
detail to openly publicize your sin
number two now let's deal with the other
individual who is has feminine features
I don't know if that's a filter I don't
know if we can't say it's wearing makeup
but it might be a filter yeah this
person I went through their videos
I genuinely well I do not know if it's a
man or a woman I do not know there might
be a hermaphrodite yes
but the point is what what is the ruling
says that the one who is born with two
genders yes they are not allowed to get
married until it is decided what they
are usually the Sharia says that the
active genitalia which they pee from
yeah or ejaculate from or whatever it
may be it is the that is the determining
factor of you being a male or a female
or some Scholars even saying which
there's a difference opinion that we
look at the certain features if this
person can have intimacy they can
impregnate then it's a man if they can
fight like a man in like the war they
can fight like a man there's some
masculine traits that are there then the
decision will be that is a man if it's a
female they have very very feminine
features
um and other factors Etc you know signs
of period or whatever it may be then
they're a woman
says that they cannot get married why
because if they are not known is it a
male or a man or a woman then marrying
imagine marrying a man and then
themselves are a man is Haram for a man
a man to marry it's it's haranda because
it's not valid if they
are a woman who say don't know and they
marry another woman then it's again not
permissible so that's why it is said
that they are they should not be married
until the decision is made clear I'm
going to leave a link from Islam q a you
can read in detail more in detail about
this but the point is what
such individuals which again goes to my
point and I'm going to wrap up on this
we think just because something looks
wrong it must be Haram just because we
have a way of looking at Islam and we
believe our Islam is the only Islam yeah
like these like this uh so-called Medina
students people are telling me
unbelievable that we think for example
I'll give you find example of the bitter
truth show some people will come and
saying this is free mixing what what is
unbelievable these are coming from
people's student knowledges that
free mixing for example doing Hajj Umbra
free mixing go into the restaurant go
into University go into work there are
Muslim men and women who go to work
where they have to work with opposite
gender is this free mixing the Sharia
had specific rules and I'm gonna put a
video of Mufti munir which explains the
balanced view not the extreme one which
is the I said I was super super salafi
brothers not all of them who think they
their Islam is the only way Islam you
don't do this you're a person of Hawa a
person of Desire there is a balance when
it comes to the bitter truth people make
comments what ignorance you have to have
number one is it haram in any
circumstance for a man or woman to talk
to each other no is it haram for a man
or woman to come in a specific setting
Haram no in the dawah when we give Dao
to the opposite agenda sometimes I speak
to three four girls they are there yeah
number one is it in public yes number
two number two is it pertaining to that
one yes when the double conversation
ends these are the conditions we follow
with the bitter truth it's the same
thing people look and think just because
this looks wrong must be Haram
it's everything is Haram it means the
more Islam is truth the prophet peace
before him said nobody overburden this
day with the religion
except that overtakes them yeah it
becomes a burden on them in the bitter
truth and I'm making a correlation here
is because you look and be like oh it
looks feminine Etc they should abandon
why should they ban him if he has that
he's born like that and he's not putting
makeup on and he's a man but he has a
very very feminine looking features how
could you stop him from the Haram of
doing praying I mean maybe he can even
give a dawah because it's not his fault
he was born like that and he's got
feminine features he looks feminine yeah
I've seen videos of this guy where other
men in beards are hugging him so he must
be a man maybe I don't know yes so the
point is what
and it is for the sake of Allah
and it is pertaining to dawah to prevent
the biggest Fitness in our time divorces
yeah and that is all I'm going to say
and anybody that doubts that and says no
you're doing it for this and this that
let's take the curse of Allah on the
liar let's take a top of Allah and say
you ask Allah's curse if I'm doing this
for clout and fame and Views and money
no problem I will also take you I will
never be sure that I'm doing this
genuinely foreign
no I ask Allah inshallah I'm doing it
for that but since you are so certain I
am doing it for those reasons us Allah
curse upon you then it's as simple as
that so the point I mentioned with the
bitter truth and this and other elements
is we have a group of Muslims who are
jahil who don't have ill now is there
can there be a difference of opinion can
there be
scholarsan you can come and look at the
bitter and say this is not permissible
100 we respect the opinion but to say
that is the opinion and there is no
opinion you are a five-star grade a
child to say that because
no it's not innovator which one do you
take in that instance there are rulings
to that which go into detail but the
point I'm seeing in I'm not sure is the
following guys just because something
looks wrong to you it doesn't mean in
the Sharia it is Haram I can give you
examples from the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him that if I mention to you I
would be like you would fall into
Comfort by saying whoever did this this
man is
said this
your jaw won't drop
yeah so we even have a fatwa when it
comes to from
um
when it comes to women doing Bawa on
camera
so the point is this don't take your
Islam from your uncle take it from the
knuckle which is the Quran and the
Sunnah don't think this looks weird
videos in this way I think he looks
Haram it must be Haram oh this looks
with that guy going to an umbra he looks
feminine it looks
when you're saying you're saying
something that Allah hasn't said that's
all I'm going to say about the sisters
among those who are on the balance path
inshallah please watch the video for
Mufti munir when it comes to percentage
remixing and inshallah the Mata is clear
with the Islam q a link when it comes to
such individuals
take care